buonasera a tutti
e buffo
sembra di 40
ma nasceva qui a bologna il
rappresentante è uno dei rappresentanti
nella quindicesima generazione di una
famiglia che alla fine del cinquecento
decise di scegliere il territorio tra
bologna e modena come sede della propria
casa della propria attività che era
quella della agricoltore quel bambino
nasce quindi all'inizio gli anni
settanta e cresce con le storie di
famiglia come tutte le famiglie hanno e
sono storie che raccontano i territori
nella famiglia in cui vive lavora dalle
dalle valli di crevalcore dai campi di
grano inframezzati e alle piantate i
filari di vite con querce agency al fino
alla collina alla vostra moggia questa
una foto di oggi non di 50 anni fa fino
ai castagneti e le montagne di zocca
quel bambino però anche la fortuna o la
sfortuna oltre di ammalarsi della stessa
passione che avevano avuto le
generazioni precedenti di crescere nei
primi anni della propria vita in quella
fase storica che gli studiosi
agricoltori chiamano rivoluzione verde e
che nasce nel secondo dopoguerra e si
consolida nel corso degli anni settanta
e ottanta rivoluzione verde perché
l'agricoltura che fino a quel momento in
tutto il mondo era sostanzialmente
rimasta uguale da millenni a causa delle
nuove conoscenze di biologia e genetica
di fisiologia vegetale animale di
chimica riceveva improvvisamente un
nuovo mandato
voi signori agricoltori dovete produrre
più cibo possibile in ogni angolo
possibile al prezzo più basso possibile
ovviamente di qualità più alta possibile
questo magari non valido per tutto il
mondo ma sicuramente per l'agricoltura
che conosciamo che quella italiana e di
quella di cui parlerò ecco così che quel
bambino che cresceva nei primi anni con
le storie che aveva sentito lo stesso
padre 35 anni prima vede improvvisamente
cambiare lo scenario quindi spariscono
le grandi famiglie contadine spariscono
le valli e le acque i problemi delle
acque dei canali della bassa bolognese
di filare di litex compaiono sostituiti
da successioni di estensioni culture
industriali e pian piano l'agricoltura
di montagna
sparisce questa è una trebbia proprio
sulla ed appennini modenesi
sostanzialmente rimane soltanto per fare
lunghe passeggiate
durante bellissime durante il weekend
questo perché evidentemente porta alla
crescita e alla cultura agricola di quel
bambino un indirizzo estremamente
preciso a un certo punto però tutto
questo
inizia a cambiare nel corso degli anni
90 il bambino diventato oggi compie gli
anni e sono io il mondo si rende conto
che non è più possibile dare questo
unico mandato all'agricoltura gli
agricoltori
bisogna affiancare un nuovo paradigma
insostituibile che quello che le risorse
non sono infinite e pertanto la stessa
agricoltura deve dare la sua contributo
e alla sostenibilità a 360 gradi quindi
anche in un contesto importante come
quella che è la lotta ai cambiamenti
climatici
quindi anche in una sfida titolo proprio
della mia presentazione che gli
agricoltori e l'agricoltura intera di
questo paese di questa regione intendono
assolutamente accettare
allora una brevissima inquadratura
inquadramento della situazione un po
italiana
i dati parlano chiaro le emissioni sono
sicuramente diciamo per la grande
maggioranza al punto vista quantitativo
provocati da altri settori perché
l'agricoltura a livello nazionale che
partecipa per il 3 per cento alle
emissioni in atmosfera e livello
regionale il 7 quindi possiamo dire ma
insomma
pensiamo ad altro in realtà non è così e
lo vogliamo fare noi stessi per primi
perché qualitativamente non c'è dubbio
che l'agricoltura partecipando solo per
il 2 per cento
avevo raggiunto del pil nazionale deve
essere definita come un settore che ha
un'impronta ecologica importante e anche
perché essendo diciamo responsabili
delle emissioni di alcuni gas
particolari che non sono
quantitativamente la co2 che occupa la
stragrande maggioranza del peso delle
emissioni di gas climalteranti
ma metano ammoniaca e protossido di
azoto derivanti soprattutto la zootecnia
ed alle concimazioni azotate dei
seminativi invernali sono elementi a
tenere assolutamente sotto controllo gli
imprenditori accettano la sfida
l'imprenditore udine magari ne accetta
la sfida
ma come cioè come ci possiamo inserire
noi in questa riflessione se
passivamente
noi sappiamo sono ormai dice 15 anni
delle direttive comunitarie via via
adottate dallo stato e dalla regione
introducono tecniche e procedure sempre
più impositive in termini di controllo
delle emissioni e noi stiamo qua
dobbiamo stare qua
ascoltiamo aspettiamo beh questo non è
il comportamento corretto
possiamo invece ragionare sul tema
cercando di individuare opportunità che
probabilmente il mercato se
correttamente comunicato potrebbe in
qualche maniera darci anche perché io vi
garantisco da agricoltore ma soprattutto
allevatore produttore di latte dal
parmigiano reggiano sentir parlare di
agricoltura sui mass media è come
diciamo contribuzione alle emissioni di
gas climalteranti solo per la parte
carne rossa demonizzandola francamente
tra l'altro ha supportato questa con
dati scientifici sempre solo
scandalistici e mai scientifici e
francamente estremamente
imbarazzante allora come può agire un
imprenditore agricolo oggi
quotidianamente sono tra i pilastri su
cui io al mattino mi sveglio insieme
alla mia famiglia a gestire l'azienda
agricola poter su cui poter agire
il primo è quello evidentemente più
ovvio cercare di aumentare la
sottrazione di co2 dall'atmosfera come
beh non col mestiere più antico del
mondo ma con il ciclo probabilmente
fisiologico più antico del mondo che la
fotosintesi clorofilliana quindi
aumentare il più possibile vegetali che
sottraggano proprio nel microcosmo
dell'azienda agricola che conduco la
sottrazione di co2 e l'emissione di
ossigeno è stato possibile abbiamo fatto
tanto l'agricoltura soprattutto
dell'emilia romagna e della provincia di
bologna che ci ha creduto nel corso
degli anni 90 e 2000 ha visto nascere
centinaia di ettari di nuovi boschi in
pianura e non in montagna
in migliaia di chilometri di nuove siepi
grazie a una politica incentivante
decisa evidentemente a bruxelles
adottata poi dalle regioni
ma non è solo questo un altro
importantissimo ruolo è svolto dalle
culture arboree della frutta questo è un
oggetto in romagna come se ne sono
tantissimi in tutta la regione che nel
corso della sua vita
evidentemente oltre a produrre frutti
preziosi che sono tips e la nostra
agricoltura sottrai con la fotosintesi e
immagazzina le proprie radici proprio
legno la co2
ecco questo io volevo sottolineare
perché quello stesso frutteto se il
consumatore che siete voi siamo noi
siamo tutti improvvisamente cessa di
apprezzare questi frutti così preziosi
non quindi non portando più
all'agricoltore al frutticoltore giusto
reddito otteniamo l'unico risultato che
questo quindi il lavoro prezioso svolto
da quel protetto nel corso di decenni
non solo viene perso ma viene reimmesso
all'interno dell'atmosfera frutticultura
uno dei tanti settori come contributo
proprio alla sottrazione della co2
secondo pilastro tutte le tecniche che
oggi sono conosciute in realtà non da
pochi anni ma già da
in una decina che possono incidere siete
la parte agronomica che per la tratte 0
tecnica a diminuire le emissioni a parte
agronomica è un mondo immenso ma tutte
le tecniche che permettono alla
conservazione del fuoco del suolo come
la minima lavorazione collaborazione
nulla possono portare una sottrazione o
come meno un contenimento delle
emissioni
le nuove tecniche per la distribuzione
corretta dei concimi azotati durante
l'inverno a livello di zootecnia
tutte sono state citate anche prima le
tecniche nuove di alimentazione dei
ruminanti che conferendo diciamo la
giusta quantità di proteina la dieta
riducono di molto le emissioni in
atmosfera e nuove tecnologie che li
siamo gli integratori inseriti
all'interno della dieta dei ruminanti
possano abbattere di molto il gas
climalteranti ci sono tutto un tema
importantissimo che è quello della
copertura degli stoccaggi dei reflui
zootecnici
anche in questo caso la possibilità in
cui possiamo operare sono altissime per
poi proseguire in quelli che sono le
tecnologie e le discipline di
distribuzione dei riferito tecnici nel
terreno
questa per noi ecco la mia circolare la
possibilità di utilizzare correttamente
rifugio tecnici senza che questi
attraverso processi e operazioni torni
nell'atmosfera estremamente importante
rimane tutto il tema anche delle energie
rinnovabili la produzione d'energia
elettrica da fonte rinnovabile
l'italia ha fatto molto in questi ultimi
dieci anni tant'è che ha raggiunto
quelli che erano gli obiettivi previsti
dagli accordi per l'europa 20 20 diversi
anni prima
e non c'è dubbio c'è anche l'agricoltura
abbia dato un contributo importante a
questo
raggiungimento di questo obiettivo
perché non soltanto attraverso la
installazione di impianti e pannelli
fotovoltaici sui capannoni sulle spalle
e sui caseifici che sono presenti nel
nostro paese ma anche e soprattutto
attraverso progetti di produzione di
energia elettrica mediante la
fermentazione di matrici organiche e
quindi attraverso biogas
io devo dire ho avuto il privilegio
della fortuna di partecipare uno di
questi progetti così importanti che è
stato è appunto la possibilità di
all'interno della stazione di
bieticoltori utilizzare le polpe di
barra d'isola quindi un sottoprodotto
dell'industria della barbabietola per la
produzione di energia elettrica
questo tra l'altro è avvenuto in un
periodo storico estremamente importante
che sono stati i primi anni 2000 in cui
l'europa decideva di abbandonare
sostanzialmente il settore dovrà vederla
da zucchero e quindi sostanzialmente di
togliere quella protezione e quella
serie di contribuzione alla produzione
che erano sia stata tipica di quegli
anni
in questa maniera la produzione di polpa
e l'utilizzo delle stesse all'interno di
impianti a biogas e quindi la loro
destinazione la produzione di energia
elettrica ha permesso di dare un valore
più alto alle colpe di vero dietro la e
quindi sostenere il fatturato da
paravento la stessa e quindi
sostanzialmente invece che destinarle
all'alimentazione animale dedicando
della produzione di energia
il risultato è stato di poter mantenere
un fatturato è sufficiente affinché
ancora oggi 35 mila ettari dice nura
padana possono essere destinati a questa
cultura
ecco questo è un po uno scenario molto
veloce di quelle che possono essere le
pratiche e i settori su cui
l'imprenditore agricolo oggi può agire
quello che va assolutamente sottolineato
è che l'agricoltura non può
l'agricoltore non può da solo sostenere
tutto questo probabilmente perché
anzi assolutamente perché la marginalità
dell'attività agricola oggi è tale per
cui non è possibile sostenere costi
aggiuntivi o diciamolo meglio in alcuni
settori specifici tutto ciò non è
possibile
mi riferisco ad esempio in particolare
al dott etnia nelle aree più fragile il
nostro paese quindi la collina e alla
montagna che si è lasciata da sola a
sostenere questo questo tipo di impegno
probabilmente sicuramente contribuirà a
un calo delle emissioni per che
chiuderanno tutte le stalle ma questo
diciamo portando poi nel paese una
problematica diversa che è quella della
gestione delle aree fragili e del
rischio idrogeologico
i binari pertanto su cui agire sono due
invece uno evidentemente e in base anche
sfruttando quelle che sono state le
esperienze degli ultimi dieci anni in
termini di politica di incentivazione
riuscire a dosare correttamente in
settori specifici e conosciuti politiche
incentivazioni corrette potrebbero
essere di energie non c'è dubbio oggi ad
esempio in corso una discussione
estremamente importante sul decreto
biometano che potrebbe coinvolgere quei
stessi impianti barbabietola che prima
abbiamo visto e di cui si potrebbe
allungare la vita mediante appunto la
possibilità di produrre bio metano ma
anche tanti altri settori
non c'è dubbio che però il binario
principale su cui occorre agire e
operare è quello di un patto tra il
produttore agricolo e il consumatore che
siamo tutti noi un patto che porti a una
consapevolezza nuova e di quello che lo
sforzo che l'agricoltura deve fare e su
quello che la conseguenza
diretta che il consumatore al momento in
cui scegli un proprio regime alimentare
ecco allora che l'agricoltore gli
agricoltori ci virtuosi devono poter
essere riconoscibili probabilmente è il
percorso di certificazione è il percorso
corretto impronta di carbonio potrebbe
essere lo stesso climate smart un
marchio volontario riconoscibile per
l'agricoltura in maniera tale che lo
sforzo che l'agricoltore da solo
incentivato andare a fare perché
convinto e responsabile dell'attività
che sta facendo venga riconosciuto dal
mercato e da questo quindi possa essere
premiato grazie